hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to markiplier adventures the
fan made game by Jeff Kyler I think is
his name and I want to apologize to him
because I've been so late in getting to
playing this game Marc finishes making
videos for the day
he's very exhausted and was about to
turn off his computer when all of a
sudden a random file popped up the name
of the file was Marc DXE curiosity took
over him and decides to check the file
but suddenly cut off the music before he
got too crazy now I had some trouble
trying to figure out how I was gonna
record this game but I'm very excited
because I found out a few things about
it beforehand anyway it said beware the
crazed monster oh no I'm afraid I might
have spoiled that a little bit for
myself but you guys didn't know about it
and also I found out this cool trick
because I was playing it over again
[Music]
good okay so obviously this game was
made in what I but maybe not obviously
to you but this game was made in game
maker and I really do appreciate when
people make me games and I am sorry that
it took me so long this was released
back in May and I found out about it in
June but I've been so busy and I got
distracted not but has been sad you've
now been sent to the hospital in an
abandoned crew free for the next two
months but you still feel minor pain boy
isn't that a pain in the ass
oh you anyway so this is where things
get a little trippy mark are you wait oh
why does my ass hurt more than my head
you have a wound on your buttocks shut
off nurse I knew that already somehow
because I felt my butt I'm sorry can we
make out yes dramatic pause nurse get
out now mark I can't leave you by my
side right now
shut up nurse okay
muah big giant boobs big giant muscles
come on Jeffrey bring it on anyway so
this is where I had trouble because the
resolution of the game keeps flipping
back and forth but either way there's a
lot of cool things to be see about this
game this is about the extent that I
played myself so from here on out it's
totally new and totally interesting oh
man like most of the games that people
have made about me there's gonna be a
lot of referential stuff to videos that
I've done in the past I'll try to
anytime there is a reference and someone
doesn't know anything about it I'm gonna
try to put links in the description
below I play just a select few of Jeff
the killer games and not only enough
unlike Slender Jeff the killer never had
a really iconic good game which is
strange because he was a really popular
creepypasta character also if you click
you shoot mustache ascend it goes poof
you managed to escape the hospital from
Jeff but then you fell into a portal
that leads to a magic land
maybe I'm over-exaggerating basically
another land that seems more familiar to
you mark
where the hell am i well then more boxes
too bad I can't smash up okay I'm dead I
forgot about that guy okay what I forgot
to mention that this is where the extent
of my knowledge is so I have not gotten
past this part sorry okay get me there
sunny Jim I don't know what these these
uh Mario guys every bullet bill I don't
know what the bullet bill guys are doing
here but either way this is a city and
now by it's totally unexplored territory
premiere hey come on you gotta give me a
chance
oh boy this is gonna be fun yep I'm
shooting the bullets in there blowing up
oh I see yeah oh yeah there you go
sometimes it's just best to spam
everybody with giant pink mustaches
murderous pink mustaches it's like a
Batarang but it's a moustache still will
kill you very dead hope you know so I'm
supposed to there we go suck suck suck
all my stashes sorry that that gets
annoying that's gonna happen a lot I
[Music]
wonder if this is in any way overkill
[Applause]
No ah here we go now do I get a
checkpoint or anything do I get like a
little bit of same because it made quite
a bit of progress and now I would
definitely like to be able to know that
I'm gonna be okay in the future no no
okay fine
they're gonna be more do I need a
hailstorm of pink death oh oh water -
wait a minute you seem to look familiar
who are you
good evening Bob my name is Wilfred I
haven't done the voice in forever hang
on let me try that again
good evening my name is Wilfred Worf -
that's WI LF Ord wait a minute how do
you know my name and why do you have the
ability to throw as many wharfs dashes
as I want oh I do I have that ability
I'm simply part of your subconscious
mind the wharfs Isis oh that's more
complex
I guess the programming in the game
happens - no you'll I bring my style not
ellipses creepy I though well how do I
get out of this game
why are you reach your greatest foe your
goal awaits you know I wish you luck
because I'll expect you need here we go
is my greatest foe the slender the
slender man I haven't seen you in a
legitimate fashion in a long time
by the way sorry for the mouse porn of
being in here there was no other way for
me to record this game without that and
mr. Slenderman you seem to be getting a
little bit close to my buttocks they
were recently stabbed by a crazed but
stabber who's much more scary than you
are so don't even try just cuz I
suddenly have two buttholes does not
mean that you need to stick your
tentacles anywhere they shouldn't be
am I supposed to know didn't affect him
in the least you would think you a nice
little animation there huh I do
appreciate the fact that this guy's made
all the art for this game you know it
might not be a very graphically
impressive game in terms of like the
engine but hey the arts pretty good I
really like the fact he obviously put a
ton of work into this seriously guy
thank you so much and now it's a black
screen I was here for I waited about 30
seconds so I'm just gonna get out and
get into part two yeah
no no come back here no no no get closer
get closer to me okay so I'm assuming
this is where I was supposed to pick up
because there was a part two and there
is a part three mark was caught by
Slenderman and blacked out he then woke
up in a strange place he knew right away
there was something up ahead he wouldn't
like what is it whoa what's up head what
don't I like oh god I didn't I expected
a lot of things but definitely not that
okay mannequin Factory I see how it is
so raspy he'll is this old explode Oh
fantastical there's a link for that in
the description as well what is that
what was that up there is that an
elevator that I need to find later boom
oh I thought I could blow up the boxes
for a second
fireworks there's like the fourth of
July except with dead mannequins wait
both deploy two coming down here only to
kill more mannequins so I'm trying to
ambush me it's actually oddly enough
because it's just a pixelated style game
it reminds me of uh some of the RPG
horror games that I played in the past
you know it's weird like thinking back
on all these various games that I've
played in the past you know I don't even
remember half of the games I played you
know every time I come across it like
when I'm trying to do a splash screen
and try to pick videos out I usually do
them by random I just like randomly
select whatever my mouse leaves on Emily
oh my
god I can't believe I remember this game
I played it so long ago and it's like
it's getting to that point in my youtube
career here that is like I've been doing
it so long that it's some of them I just
think totally slipped my mind but it's
always so cool to see because I look
back in like ah cows such a dweeb still
AM so that's good the dweeb ish mist is
very pervasive if you didn't know
especially in the Fishbach bloodline
there's my last name is you do know some
people don't even know my life name how
dare you I dare all of you
how dare all of you be so awesome and
amazing the greatest fans in the world
in my opinion especially for making cool
games like this for me ah that almost
crushed me by douche douche Vader
douchey Vader how about you get over
thank you thank you thank you Gary
enough I don't actually know where I'm
supposed to go if I was supposed to
collect something or if I'm just kind of
going on a little murder spraying all
these mannequins they don't deserve to
die but maybe they could get a job in a
store that I never go to or something
like that
my suppose it oh oh oh no no okay this
is gonna be hard jump come on come on
come on come on come on
there we go why did it go all the way
back that time I didn't okay never mind
you know what I'm not gonna ask
questions about now I'm gonna assume
that those gonna be another one over
here and up nope not today Kenz oh we're
I'm a falling part of our fell to a set
of two doors he entered the one on his
left mark if you're reading this I fully
recommend you taking the door and you
left because I definitely guarantee
you'll love it that just makes me really
want to go on the one on the right what
are you doing wait a minute no did I
miss something we're gonna build some I
wasn't talking to you ah we're gonna
revisit our statues of Wade
I remember us doing that yes of course I
do you got I was there you know guys
know I never regretted making my statue
yeah we could tell oh I'm trying to do
my best Bob hey Mark I think me and Wade
found something over here in the cave
what is it we've ordered dojo we see I
can't shoot mustaches at them oh my god
it's totally the statue wait up there
that's awesome
but they feel really bad because I feel
like I missed out on something what did
I miss out on it was specifically for me
but I felt as though if you would have
said that he would have known that I
would have not gone that way oh there's
a huge hole here how can you tell Oh God
why do our minds have to be in the
gutter that's a Wade's mind is usually
the most in the gutter oh dear
what does Bob said oh dear anyway is
there anything in here I think it's a
portal to another dimension good
observation Oh
want to be here and build something but
I have to get out of this game I guess
I'll have to jump down here I wish you
luck mark so do i shut up Wade
thanks guys well here I go what if I
jump over it
Oh sick moves well what are you gonna do
okay this is not very nervous bye to be
continued in the third part real quick
I'm gonna see I'm gonna actually go back
and I'm gonna see what happened in the
thing that I missed so about one second
before the transition oh it's so hot
right now the air isn't working very
well okay but I'm here all right
Margarita's left okay left I got it with
a ride with Santa okay
[Music]
markiplier couldn't be finally back my
little pretties who's gonna say what's
how the world will try at all
who's that over there oh no that's my
danger on the island or plan a drink boy
you watch a dog that is not doing so
good right now
I status won't be navigating it sub
capacity because navigating challenges
let's see L take care of that joyfully
enjoys the benefits to be the man in
charge without any hassle
holy crap your computer but really
socking this is coffee get your lag hey
come on see any why you gotta be so mean
do you realize that your Chi actually
talking to yourself I said a lot of
people think that it's a pretty pathetic
I know everyone gets that you're
actually oh oh I see the arrow keys I
wheel and he's my little LV I had no
idea that we're all on the framerate one
fellow was a [ __ ] don't ever repeat
that to anyone because I don't want to
get out the fans actually in comedy well
mrs. Claus loudly ages ago in the North
Pole nights the only thing to keep me
warm with the entrails of my murdered
reindeer and the kids knew all very old
young bodies well this rainbow
background of Santa's LSD trip
we're bleeps over and over good good job
blocking that little kitty all the
sudden you got launched off Santa [ __ ]
and found a dark land which you
currently need to find someone else to
bail for oh I miss so much more
[Music]
that's actually that actually sounds
quite terror okay that FC sounds quite
terrifying that's one of my favourite
things that came out of one of the like
least interesting games that I ever
played oh my god it I found the
blacksmith oh yeah you teleport you land
a Minecraft okay we've already seen this
part so I'm gonna skip to the third part
of the game all right here we go part
three
previously on markiplier adventures mark
encounter did friends
encounter did friends Bob and Wade in
the world of Minecraft but sadly rach
had to leave them by jumping into a
portal in order to escape from the game
what what oh my god it's dark liar
it's dark oh donker the guys of the fans
made them I never really publicly
acknowledged the seriously dark a blur
if you if you've heard of him in the
fanbase it's an entirely fan created
contract I mean sure yeah I made these
videos that were supposed to be really
creepy but it was the weirdest thing
like darker buyer started out as a super
sinister guy and then he became like the
emo modern vampire roommate of mine that
was just kind of angsty and listened to
too much I don't know Lincoln Parker
Coldplay what's that I don't listen to
music that much so
My Chemical Romance brand-new Dashboard
Confessional taking back sunray and
Death Cab for Cutie wait who's that oh
no it's gone or he's here whoa nice
little animation dude that's really
awesome oh that's not good
I know it and on that day humanity got a
reminder of what it was like to live in
a cage I think I think that's what's
going on there
oh thank god the guy musket man made the
mark man or whatever don't remember his
name
oh my goodness gravy is this a boss
battle oh I died I thought okay well
then yay for failure let's try that
again Sark bye oh they bounce too back
at me and you'd find a better way to go
about this
sorry you douche you can't bounce back
by bus dashes of glory wait a minute oh
oh so bad we think you're gonna kill me
oh you gotta be I'll get you but this
isn't this isn't very sporting I need to
confront you mano a mano
I did it I did I killed him with my
mustaches very strange is that it okay
so I'm gonna watch the video and also
I'm gonna add the video in to the video
so it seems like you're watching it with
me okay here we go Oh dad
oh really cool oh man that's awesome
I didn't know that it could cause it
explode take it easy there Goku was that
me zooming off into the distance was I
team rocket blasting off again
congratulations mark thank you thank you
so much for making this game that was
awesome
you've escaped the clutches of this game
and defeated the mark the opponent of
all from within now you are safe and
sound in your home dot dot dot or was it
a dream oh man I'll be so sad if all of
YouTube that I did was a dream oh that
would be crushing either way you are
safe now but your adventures are not
over therefore to be continued dude I
hope you make another one I will so
gladly paid this was awesome seriously
it may not seem to you guys that's all
that a spectacular game but just from my
standpoint seeing that someone like
follows my stuff so much that they made
a whole game about and spent time and
effort and probably a lot of it and
making this game to get all the
references in there because there's such
a big fan and just thank you man so much
for making this this was amazing and
thank you guys so much for supporting my
channel through this entire time check
out the videos in the description I
tried to link him in the order that they
were presented you know throughout the
game I'll do my best Arif I if I miss a
few let me know in the comments I'll try
to fix them back but there's one more
thing in here that I kind of want to see
what it is so once again here we go
[Music]
that video is from some bullcrap I do
hello markiplier adventures called
markiplier in slow motion
Oh game created by John J Howell okay
his name was Jeff Kyler
but John Howell thank you so much man if
you want to see this video go right head
and that music god I have not heard that
music in forever oh my god that is so
incredibly was that particular music was
like one of the first times that ever
put music into an outro and the first
time I did that was for when me and Wade
made this uh sketch comedy that created
wharfs ash called the fall of Slender
Man you can watch that down below it's
one of the first things we ever did it's
really poor quality but you know in my
heart it's just like one of the coolest
things that I've ever made because I
knew nothing about making those types of
videos and that was awesome anyway
message to markiplier you've inspired me
to do better and inspire other people I
one day want to be like you be a force
for good and raise money for charity
just like your fans we all care and love
you Marc feel free to contact me anytime
John J how seriously you are awesome and
fans like you are the reason why I keep
moving forward I would be nothing like
quickly and I don't even know how it
happened I think this is 50,000 you did
it I look so young and as always I will
see you in the next video got it it
looks so young oh man it's amazing how
much I've aged in two years oh that's so
cool everyone check out his youtube
channel
Jeff Kyler 14 is his username cuz it's
so cool oh man I'm I'm just I'm tickled
to death by it it's the coolest thing
that's crashed ok that did crash it's
the coolest thing just seriously thank
you guys so much for being awesome and
just being great fans you are so
important to me and this channel is so
important to me and then what we do is
so important so thank you so much and
also I've said it a lot now charity
livestream this weekend July 12th if
you're watching this in the future
obviously you've missed
they'll be more in the future so just
thank you guys so much for giving me
this chance thank you for making this
game for me and thank you for all the
stuff that you have made for me in the
past there's just like so much love from
this community and there's so much good
stuff coming out of this community you
know not just for me not for me it's for
like everyone like after that one video
where I talked about depression you know
so many people send me emails about how
they had talked with other members of
the community and they were able to like
finally open up about certain issues
that they've been you know harboring and
holding in and the fact that you guys
were able to do that because it's not
just about like make you stuff for me or
trying to make me feel special it's
about you know connecting with each
other and I know that I said I was gonna
get the website up and running to get a
forum so you guys could all talk in one
place there was a little bit of a hitch
in that sorry I am trying my best to get
that up I don't know anything about web
development so I'm having to go through
other channels but if need be I will
like do whatever it takes to get that up
and running as soon as possible so
seriously thank you guys so much for
watching once again all the videos that
were referenced in this game are in the
description below so thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]
in case you didn't know yeah that you
can tell I mean obviously
[Music]
Oh